It wasn't a runaway hit, but The Boy was still
one of the strangest mainstream horror films
of 2016.
Whether you missed out on the first movie
or just need a primer for part two, here's
everything you need to know about Brahms:
The Boy II.
In The Boy, an American nanny named Greta
is hired by an eccentric rich family, the
Heelshires, for a very unconventional job.
They want her to care for a porcelain doll
named Brahms.
Hey, a job's a job, right?
The family gives Greta a very specific set
of rules by which to care for the doll, including
talking to him loudly and freezing meals for
him.
It also turns out that the real Brahms was
the son of the Heelshires, and he was killed
in a house fire 20 years ago on his eighth
birthday after one of his young friends was
found in the forest with her skull crushed.
Suspicious, right?
Naturally, Greta ignores the rules, at least
at first.
But then, the weird stuff starts piling up.
Brahms seemingly moves on his own, and a child's
voice and sobs can be heard throughout the
mansion.
Skip to the end, and Greta discovers that,
lo and behold, the real Brahms has been alive
and well, and he's now a grown man who's been
living in the walls of the house.
"They're in the walls."
"They're in the walls!"
After this shocking reveal, a tussle ensues,
and Greta eventually fights him off and flees
the estate.
But as we discover later, Brahms is still
alive, and he's busy fixing his shattered
doll.
Greta might've escaped, but it seems that
the Heelshire house might still be housing
Brahms, and that he and his doll are out to
torment whoever occupies the mansion next.
In Brahms: The Boy II, a young family will
be moving into the Heelshire Mansion with
no knowledge of the place's dark history.
"You should Google it.
It's horrifying."
When the new family shows up, the young son
of the family will find and befriend the spooky
porcelain doll.
Considering that the first film showed the
Heelshires harboring plans to turn Greta into
a mate for the real Brahms, this spells some
pretty terrible things for this particular
young boy who will be unaware of the malevolent
force he may be inviting into his life.
Director William Brent Bell and screenwriter
Stacey Menear are back for The Boy sequel
to finish what they started.
Speaking in an interview with Cosmopolitan,
the screenwriter discussed how the first movie
was built around its central twist that Brahms
was in the walls.
Now that that's out in the open, there's no
telling where the story could go.
As he put it,
"I think there's a lot of other interesting
stuff you can focus on now.
Because the audience knows going in what the
thing is."
The lead role in the first Boy movie was played
by Lauren Cohan of The Walking Dead, but as
far as we know, she's not coming back for
act 2.
In her place, former Dawson's Creek cast member
Katie Holmes is playing Liza, a mother who
moves into the mansion with her husband and
young son.
As a real-life mother to a young daughter,
Holmes didn't have to dig too deeply to inhabit
the role of a mom terrified for the safety
of her child.
In June 2019, Holmes told Entertainment Weekly,
"I felt like this was a story about a mother
and her child and this evil presence that's
influencing her child, and how that's a universal
fear for every parent."
But there's also another fear that Holmes
apparently discovered during the making of
the film: dolls.
Those things'll get you every time.
"I tell you, this doll is pretty spooky."
In an interview with Access Hollywood, Holmes
stated that working on the movie was a pretty
creepy experience, especially when she was
working one-on-one with the doll.
"I loved dolls growing up, so I was like,
'This is really ruining dolls for me.'"
Rising star Christopher Convery, who you might
remember as depicting a young Billy from Stranger
Things in those season three flashbacks, is
playing Jude, the boy who becomes Brahms'
new buddy.
Considering the history of Brahms, who had
his childhood taken away from him, it's possible
that Jude could be targeted as part of some
scheme for Brahms to reclaim the childhood
he lost.
Or if the Heelshires are somehow still lurking
about, it’s possible that they simply want
the young boy to replace the son they hid
behind the walls over 20 years ago.
Either way, this kid and his family are probably
in for a bad time.
Composer Bear McCreary provided an eerie classical
piano score for the first Boy movie, giving
the story a distinctly vintage, haunting feel.
For the sequel, however, a new composer is
stepping up for the job in the form of musician
Brett Detar.
The musician previously collaborated with
William Bell, the director behind Brahms,
by composing the nerve-grating score for his
2012 possession movie, The Devil Inside.
As a solo artist, Detar's music is primarily
folk influenced, which could impact the feel
of his score.
It could also indicate that Brahms: The Boy
II could have a slightly different vibe and
atmosphere than the first film.
Originally, Brahms: The Boy II was all set
to be a summer movie, with a release date
set for July 2019.
Then the film was pushed to December, and
then February, No official reason behind the
delays was given, but it's been speculated
the film was moved to give it space from other
spooky doll films like Child's Play and Annabelle
Comes Home.
The film's original release date could have
also given the movie direct competition from
other horror movies such as Crawl and Ready
or Not.
No such concerns at the start of a year.
Now scheduled for February 21st, the film's
new release slot will put the boy up against
Birds of Prey, Sonic the Hedgehog, and Vin
Diesel's Bloodshot, so if you're in a horror
mood that weekend, your only option is lurking
somewhere in the walls.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.